hey guys it's a scene and I'm here with
my two sisters this is Jenna and this is
Bree hello hi did you know that I have
another sister this is Bree she is
breathe that's the only way that we can
explain it but one thing about Bree that
you need to know is the shoe hubs or
even I do if you think the general likes
Oreos Bree and weaves you're on vacation
there'd be like a pool area and I'd be
up on the upper level deck and I would
try to circle or I has into your mouth
into the pool while you would lay there
remember wow they're probably taking a
nap yeah I think that's probably in a
nap
you seemed super doctors it is oh by the
way it's national Wario day that's why
we video we yeah wait let me double
check if it's nationally scary I don't
this irrational definitely not
international you are you saying that
Oreos aren't international national Oreo
day is March 6th so be ready to observe
by having your glass of milk Andy yeah
as it is national Oreo cookie day this
day is recognized across the nation each
year on March 6 muscle very privately
know you're celebrating now publicly
I'll celebrate privately let's celebrate
first thing we're gonna but what do you
want to but first this we're gonna say
that for life oh my gosh don't even ask
what do you want to so higher let's open
this one no let's do you want because
you find you and ask us let's open the
more the music books because I'm really
excited about what's in there I think
it's gonna be so you know I don't know
she's like she see okay so the first
thing we're gonna open is the Oreo Music
Box I have no idea what this is I
basically went on Amazon and I found as
many Oreo as I could you place a whole
Oreo on a turntable I love that oh I
thought it was gonna be an actuary is
amused
arms to the center that worry of music
will begin playing whoa I love white
fudge Oreos - they're the best and look
at this cute little you know they used
to make these all the time they did
that's a lie maybe they just brought
them back check the expiration date
there's my favorite same ones limited
edition here they are so everything that
came in here was the white fudge Oreos
unboxing it privately though this
batteries are included
she unbox the privately Aubry unboxed it
privately mmm here's the music box
you're watching the open it it's here
it's here the final product is here why
do you need to see that trash oh because
people hook ah it's gonna boxing oh my
gosh mean I can record but this is the
final product it's all you hear about a
product here's actually a really great
point you know so I needed with the Oreo
on it - yeah what kind and it said the
thin really what's the direction oh
please a whole Oreo cookie on attorney
oh my gosh these are but these have been
damaged
those are we need a big compromise
during the music box arm to the center
of the Oreo cookie music will begin
playing good time Eugene fight from the
worry of the song change
[Music]
I'm gonna get hands dirty steppin on the
divan we need friends for my palate oh
my gosh yeah doesn't bleh
amazing gigabyte oh no what have you
done you hog no it says you take a bite
goodbye this is we really had a good
time well it worked that's a new tune
recording turn the arms the edge of the
turntable you changed
that's something amazingly what's
happening is there's little sensors here
so whichever ones are available no yeah
this is magic yes it's magic so you
can't give away the tricks I know what's
your what is wrong with you the more you
eat the better the song gets that wait
let's go to the next thing you're right
we should I'm losing interest quickly if
we're losing interest they're losing
interest we're going to the next one
breanne like to candy canes also I don't
really but you don't know bran likes
candy canes one for you laundry how do
you eat your candy cane I usually don't
even like this but
I'm really wanna get that don't eat
anything in your mouth oh I don't like
it oh it kind of smells like wood this
is like if I like the carpet you do not
like it Christmas is canceled I'm gonna
take your word for it and see it sucks
we did not enjoy that
anyway smell it pie look at his eye Adi
I do not like oh it opens inside imagine
I don't want to tell you that but I did
see that what are you saying knives up
here
I almost got knocked over by that
question I have not been delivered in
transitive I don't know okay best buy
January 27th of 2019 okay we're good
we're not good
oh it's spoiled I am so upset I just
bought all of these things on Amazon I
want you to know that someone's getting
a bad review okay gift set what do we do
with this little wait first date here
June let's talk about the plot with a
little pie the pie is the pike pot isn't
expired this is cute oh that's nice yeah
it was a ceramic you can use that we're
abs dishwasher safe and oven safe
microwave may become hot okay you know
what's not the expired ingredients no
this is a weapon like in the cartoons
they do not do that though okay well
that's unfortunate so basically you're
supposed to rinse the pie dish combine
the chocolate pudding mix in a small
bowl and then you put it in here and you
put this little it's spoiled
uh-huh all this crap is happy Oreo day
I've been spoiled it all so these are
it's all Christmas stuff look it has
Christmas on the front it does have
Christmas decor no that's just a find
you're just late nope that's Christmas
look look look no it has Christmas a
lime tree yeah for Christmas it's a
great point okay Wow lawyer is all
spoiled we need something to hold so let
me show you me and thought it's reusable
[Applause]
so all you do is real cookies vanilla
ice cream 1/2 a cup milk blend this is
not a very high quality it's heavy
yeah ok what was fun about this your
India I was promised fun fun about this
this is a key you know that the big one
here eat this no expired it wasn't
this is not expired this is no Christmas
stuff yes you guys like to do getting
paper and shoot paper Watsonville your
paper wad
look at this expiration oh I've been tap
was kind of in the January 1 why it is
so upsetting
no Rick sadistic or definitely give you
guess before Christmas it's like does
that mama go wait let's go there's a
last one it's in the book this is
something that I'm very excited about
hey hey but get into this I'm into it
I'm into it you lost my interest when I
went to open it first
Oh symbiosis studies the stuff you've
seen and stuff the study you could win
oh oh you can win prizes oh but guess it
ends on three six we can still win if
you a the way to either word you scan
Oreo cookie and you could win over a
million dollars prizes how do I do it
desire arises no it will it expires
today oh three six nine six it's so good
we missed the inbox so inside check the
date best before September 2019 all
right this is something really this is
the most stuff you know the most cream
ever
I've never seen the video of the ideas
rise at a hundred layer Rio front
table so is it June 18th or 19th or do
1908 it's fine don't worry about it it's
not your eating this wasn't a thing in
2008 wasn't this is now what if you put
stuff with the stuff so anyone there's
listening stuff yeah I don't think
there's some missing they're missing
no there's oh my god not even taking the
oreo holy like you didn't do no ice
what's just open this doesn't even have
an end this is insane look Ethan Oreo
conspiracy no it definitely is because
look this one is one two three four five
awesome for this this is a conspiracy
chain we need is your actual conspiracy
this is the most real conspiracy that
I've ever seen how many are there we
need we need to do something here
supposed to be in this there should be
18 cookies 12 13 14 15 16 17 17 that
doesn't even count better than ever
okay somebody's like cookies
I'm not even those now I thought you
miss either my days ruined my days
almost missed Oreos Wow what the super
thick one of the beatbox weird it's
barely in there so this has been real
fun this is crazy this is this this is a
conspiracy at all pharisee because
where's the Oreo I'm writing into Oreo
five six seven eight nine ten wonderful
rows look at that look the other half of
this isn't even there I'm upset I'm so
sorry
although I'm very excited it's national
oriented a I'm gonna celebrate on you oh
gosh which punch seven let's celebrate
something else what celebrate some
tomorrow March 7 it's Alexander Graham
Bell day oh my gosh name tag day
national cereal day national crown roast
of pork day mmm he's having better
national cereal day
I'm a Lent we can't wait
yeah lunch we can all eat fish
sandwiches I don't want to we have its
national cheerleading Week national
dental assistants recognition week
national pet sitters a week o national
procrastination week that's cool
National School Breakfast Week I'm in
women in construction they don't care
okay well thanks guys for joining the
astrological signs Pisces okay this is
over thank you guys so much for watching
make sure you subscribe to youtube.com
slash it's me to tell your Oreo days
yeah check your dates this is I've been
scammed this is a conspiracy conspiracy
tweet chain let him know cuz this is
just about acceptable
Chucky's off the hook Oreo is a
lifestyle but this is a lie alright see
ya hey
[Music]
and we want a burger burger on the house
burger guys all my things were expired
yeah
[Music]